that's not all you got you thought you
were empty but you got a half tank left
and that's all you need to get where
you're going you can fill up later keep
going keep going keep going sometimes
you got to sit with the pain until the
pain
passes sometimes pain will immobilize
you but as long as you can feel it you
can push it without pain without
sacrifice We Have Nothing Without Pain
without sacrifice we have
nothing please don't give up
remember this is the
grind find a way to push through the
suffering and discomfort and I promise
you there is something great waiting for
you on the other
side just keep grinding don't give
up this is not the time
[Music]